And again, this is Dr. Kevin Cutters, continuing our series on the different factors that we're looking at in genetic testing, why we do genetic testing, and this one is the importance of
S-O-D. So S-O-D is not sod, it is super oxide dismutase. So sod is important if you're putting it in a new house, so it looks nice, but wife would love it.
So, but now we're not talking about that. Super oxide dismutase. What is it? Why do we look for it? Why is it important?
Okay, so super oxide dismutase fits into the metabolic picture in this Transulferation pathway.
Thank you again to Dr. Ben Lynch, seekinghealth.org for these nice posters that he's created. So super oxide dismutase fits into the Transulferation pathway.
So these are the metabolic pathways that we're looking at. Remember each one of these little bubbles here is a G that creates an enzyme that creates the ability for that substrate A to move to substrate B so that we can sustain life.
Well, S-O-D is right there on this pathway. So again, in this series, we're going to break apart all these pathways to help everybody better understand it.
So let's take a real close look right at that picture of S-O-D. What is it? It is an antioxidant.
What super oxide dismutase gene does and actually makes three different enzymes, S-O-D-1, 2, and 3, found in different parts of your body and your cells?
It takes super oxide, which is a free radical and converts it into hydrogen peroxide.
Your body needs super oxide at different times but it's all in balance. Where do we make too much super oxide in the case scenario of someone having a defect on the S-O-D gene?
They will be not able to convert super oxide into hydrogen peroxide. They will have an excess of super oxide and that does a whole bunch of damage in your body and makes you sick.
So it converts super oxide radical into hydrogen peroxide. Super oxide is constantly formed in your body. So this is what it looks like.
If super oxide gene is defective, not only will you increase in the S-O-D gene is defective, not only will you increase super oxide radical but what are the other problems with that is that super oxide radical.
Combines with nitric oxide to form peroxidite rate which is very damaging to your cells. Also it's steelyed up your nitric oxide.
Now if you've listened to my nitric oxide lecture, you've remembered that there's really three forms of nitric oxide in your body.
Indusible nitric oxide synthase which is the part of nitric oxide that helps to kill pathogens. You have endothelial nitric oxide.
That is the part of nitric oxide that helps to keep your blood vessels, the endothelial cells of your blood vessels open.
And deficiency of that can cause vasoconstriction, increase blood pressure, and cardiovascular disease. You also have neuronal nitric oxide synthase which affects your muscles and affects your brains and your neurons.
So nitric oxide is very important where you have an excess of super oxide free radicals. It combines with your nitric oxide and creates peroxidite rate which is equally damaging to the super oxide ion to your cells and it's steelyed all your nitric oxide, not a good thing to happen.
Proxy nitrate and super oxide are damaging to cells, damages DNA, damages your lipid membranes, increases aging, increases cancer risk, chronic inflammation is a major player in ALS, it is a huge player in cardiovascular disease.
So watch my nitric oxide presentation for that and it will really help you understand it a little better.
Here's a really article that was in Nature Reviews Neuroscience talks about in the cytoplasm muted SOD, so a defect in SOD1 which is the SOD that's in the cytoplasm of the cell, it increases apoptosis of the cell.
So we're not talking about healthy apoptosis when we're trying to kill cancer cells, we're talking about early cell death and early aging.
So it damages the mitochondria, it decreases ATP production of the mitochondria so it can lead to chronic fatigue and inability to deal with chronic infections and ultimately cell death, not a good thing.
So any decrease in super oxide dissipates is a bad thing, so we want to look at that when we look at a gene profile.
But in fact it's been found that humans produce an average of 90 micrograms per milliliter of SOD and live an average of about 80 years.
You look at other species, chimpanzees produce an average of 40 micrograms per milliliter of SOD and they live an average of 40 years.
Fruit flies that have it bred to produce twice as much SOD as normal live twice as ordinary fruit flies.
So SOD is a major component of aging and health and longevity, interesting note there that was kind of a cool correlation.
So this SOD gene is important, we have to make sure that if there is a defect, what are we going to do about it?
So see that it requires copper, zinc and meganese because really SOD1, SOD2 and SOD3 are a little bit different, they require different ones of these minerals in order to be created to create super oxide dissipates.
So we want to look at the cofactors, these are considered cofactors in this case, to increase that to help this gene function.
But remember, we don't want to just give SOD, there's SOD supplements out there on the market and you do it to be careful whether they're even stable past the hydrochloric acid or you're stomach.
But you don't want to make the mistake of, oh I have this gene so I'm going to take a whole bunch of methyl tetrahedral folate.
I have an SOD gene defect so I'm going to take a whole bunch of SOD, though it can be beneficial to take a little, you have to remember that it's a part of a bigger picture.
So this is the pathway that SOD has founded, the Transulferation Pathway, and you see how each one leads to the other.
If you add one of these things to the puzzle, you're disrupting the whole big picture, that's why we always say you have to follow the rules, never treat the SNP itself.
The best tip is a single nucleotide polymorphism that we're talking about with an SOD polymorphism.
So if I have a single nucleotide polymorphism of my SOD gene, you don't want to just give SOD, you have to look at the bigger picture, look at the whole person and look at the cause.
So just because I have a polymorphism and I have a decreased production of SOD, what else is part of that picture?
Does this person have Lyme disease? Do they have a chronic infection? Do they have whatever?
And then you have to look at what's upstream and downstream of that, and how am I affecting that?
So make sure that we do that.
We obviously never use protocols to treat everybody differently in the tweak it along the way.
And then look at this, I only showed you the bottom right Transulferation Pathway.
I circled SOD at the bottom right here, but Transulferation Pathway is a part of a huge bigger picture.
So you have to be careful in doing supplementation because you're affecting the whole giant picture of the whole scheme of things.
So hope that helped you understand SOD just a little bit.
If you have questions, call our office to learn more about it.
If you've never had any genetic testing, call our office and we can talk about it as well.
Thank you very much.